hello and welcome to another episode of
GameSpot of Thrones I'm Lucy joined as
always by Kate hello and Dave hey there
and we're going to delve in deep into
last night's episode which is season 6
episode 5 the door so this is your
spoiler warning if you haven't seen it
turn away now but for those of you who
have and who have your emotions back in
check let's talk about it well I think
we're all a little bit devastated with
the big death at the big in both senses
of humor uh at the end of last night's
episode but before we talk about that
okay work cuz let's save that because
we're so much to talk about with lovely
Hodor Dave what happened at the wall so
we see Sansa meet up with Littlefinger
the first time since they last met when
he gave her away to Ramsey mm-hmm boy
boy boy Ramsay oh boy living I look
mother both my boys basically she's not
very happy to see little finger as last
time they were together he was just
giving her away to Ramsey and we all
know how that turned out not well she
basically tells him get us I don't need
your army he's offering all these men
he's got and he's that don't need them
but if you do happen to know with the
black fishes would appreciate it so
little finger does to tell her where is
where to find him and then she just
heads back to Castle black and they
start talking about their grand master
plan of reinforcements as Sir Davos
plainly makes out we do not have enough
men so their plan seems to be they're
going to go through all the small houses
are still loyal to the Starks they can
hang out the blackfish and that's that's
where they leave Castle black with all
their friends in tow we see as a nice
little smile from tormund Giantsbane
that's what my highlight of the episode
those two the happiest moment of those
like 45 minutes super the others though
devils and the red woman helped a man
murder his own brother with blood magic
and when Stannis paid for his crime
where were they already out looking for
a leader with better prospects and that
wildling fellow with the beard John
isn't torment
John isn't Davos for the red woman or
Stannis for that matter John is John
he's my brother he'll keep me safe I
trust him I just a hop skip and a jump
over to Pike the the Kingsmoot is taking
place and Yara puts a forward and it
kind of looks like Theon's like maybe
i'll be picking but no he actually does
back Yara as per his promise well Ramsey
like completely removed his backbones
yeah as amongst other bone related
thanks just he can't really be king he
can't make any airs anymore so that's
true but I got hyped for Yara hmm and
then you're on turns up is like actually
think you'll find that I've got a really
good idea and is ideally and actually
Iran's turned up his ideas to basically
get all his boats go across the sea see
Denarius impressive like a girl look at
all these boats that I have embarrassing
with Wars yeah it's dong holy boats and
then apparently that's gonna make her
want to marry him yeah he'll bring all
the dragons back and invade the rest of
rest of the kingdom showed the bish some
boats yes love boat man lose boats I had
I heard yours burned down well I got
plenty and then he gets coronated in the
weirdest coronation I've ever seen he's
basically drowned and given the lamest
crown hmm I've ever seen in my life some
sticks in it yeah and whilst well that
nonsense going on Yara and Theon's just
like let's just go let's take these
boats and we'll get there first and they
just vanish the bit I like about the
Kingsmoot is when everyone's chanting
the names the first of all they're very
easily won over a second of all their
names sound exactly just get your honor
yeah I never be like yeah that one where
are my niece and nephew
let's go bird
over to Braavos then and a girl is still
not ready so wie geht's cio fighting
again with the waif and the way seems to
have some kind of personal vendetta she
refers to Aria's lady Stark which is bit
notis not supposed to do that she was to
call it by a girl a girl has no name but
who still has a name she says she's not
ready and then jack n agrees um I don't
know it feels like I is still enraged
and that's maybe why she's not
progressing with her training as much as
I guess the house of black and white
would like her to the jack and shows up
and tells her a little bit back story
about the Faceless Men none of the first
faceless men were born to lords and
ladies they begin as slaves in the minds
of Valyria who was first he was no one
Jack and then gives her her first
essentially hitman contract and I it's
basically a test as well because the the
lady it's a lady crane is an actress and
she's performing in a play which is
basically how Ned and and Rob Robert it
was a series 1 recap basically it was
like a series 1 in 2 minutes and oh yeah
I like someone on the subreddit pointing
this out oh you had the exact same role
in both she was in the crowd just
watching a dag get beheaded and she's
watching lady crane portray Cersei
Lannister and you know like she sort of
watches the play I think the play goes
one little bit too long ago um and then
she's talking again to Jack in and she's
like okay well I think I think Lady
Queen is actually quite decent person
and I think it's like this younger
actress who's got it out for who set the
contract out and jackin kind of does a
bit of a sad bit of foreshadowing let's
just say in his cryptic response also a
couple of shout outs in this moment
because we see a just a full-frontal
penis flight center frame but also
shadow to Richard II grant because he
has a great little cameo in a bit
elsewhere in the east sir friendzone
surge or of the house frenzy oh my god
this bit was so awkward is that is what
I just described it so jores basically
you know Danny forgives him sort of and
yours laughter
saving a life like sometimes down and
he's like oh Tyrion was right I love you
I've always loved you and then Daenerys
like horribly out of extreme awkwardness
starts crying because he's done that in
front of the guy that she's boning yeah
and then he's like well I'm gonna go
away lyrics I'm a grayscale and then
she's like no I command you to find a
cure so Majid that bear was just this oh
my god okay like yeah just go ahead and
get gokyo your incurable disease that's
uh I do wonder if that's maybe like
subtle promo for her new film that's
kind of same plot oh yeah God that might
be really terrible tie-in yeah and then
back in marine Tyrion and Varys have
managed to secure a very fragile peace
that they're patting themselves on the
back and then they decided to pull out a
sweet PR campaign and enlist the help of
the red priestess who got a new red
priestess her name is keen vara or
kinvara they were talking in Valyrian so
the pronunciation might be a little off
and who in she now believes the dinero's
is the one that was promised so virus
who's quite rightfully very skeptical
says well you're the red priestess
Melisandre said the Stannis was the one
who's promised and look where he is now
but then kinvara like oh well let's talk
about this very specific religious
moment experience that you had when your
bishop was cut off Bishop when the
pillow is separated from the stone that
was better so I don't know a virus seems
pretty pretty scarce his face when it
turns into it unto like after hearing
all this is just like you know really a
reaction meme anyway kate back up to the
rest of the north yes the rest of the
North being brand sitting inside a big
old tree cave and this episode it was
called the door but it might as well be
called bran messed up because that is
the running theme of this episode and
maybe this entire series so far maybe
the entire like everything it might turn
out that bran is to blame for everything
bad that's ever happened not george RR
martin actual brand okay maybe george RR
martin is bran twist so it turns out
first of all the children of the forest
are to blame of the white
because but technically the men are to
blame because they attacked them and
they were just doing it to protect
themselves but either way it was a
terrible idea how do you even find out
that that happens they got a lot of
things like oh I'm just gonna try
sticking this thing is just one more
experiment look what do we do with this
but anybody in that guy's already has
the tracer why not and then Brown gets a
bit bored as you would there's nothing
to do in that cave and decides to go
wandering round and green seeing dreams
without the permission or the guidance
of three eyed Raven the dream he chooses
or maybe not chooses to go into is just
a bunch of white Walker standing around
he's walking through them showing off
the impressive CGI and maybe even
practical effect they're not going on
very good very nice then he walks up to
the night's king and despite knowing
that he can have some effect on the past
he goes right up to the night's king and
the night's king touches him and he
wakes up in a bit of a panic and he goes
you know he saw me like it the low kick
is on me O God and the rehydrate was
just like well you've messed up okay
chief I'd feel like if the three-eyed
Raven had just told him like oh by the
way just just don't touch anything yeah
oh but no there's all these time loops
going on we don't really know what
anyone's motivations are anymore so
maybe he knew was going to happen anyway
but either way the night's king touches
him and that gives the night's king like
the ability to actually invade the cave
whereas before he didn't that's off his
GPS yeah yeah so then they they attack
pretty soon afterwards there's a brief
scene where mirror and Hodor ago mmm
eggs on eggs lovely just like this weird
product placement bags buy eggs today
and we get excited because maybe they'll
get to eat eggs and shortly afterwards
no no eggs for anyone oh sorry and then
we just see everyone died I mean
literally everyone rewires Omega 0
because one kid will not listen to
orders throughout the entire everything
of Game of Thrones he's never listen to
orders and now that's caused the death
of the three-eyed Raven who gets stabbed
by the night's king we see Leif who does
a sort of i am legend style sacrifice
it's beautiful turns out they have
grenades thrown
I mean we were started watching just
gonna rest a row it probably the second
saddest death of the episode summer some
odd Zeus as soon as someone came
on-screen I just wait don't do it please
the word because we don't see summer
that much and then summer turns up and
just runs right into the fray and well
we just see blood going everywhere and
it's not very nice cmas do much either
just sort of jumped in action
immediately but the death of the
direwolves is meant to symbolize you
know the death of that childhood so
finally we might get to see brand
growing up a little bit he's got the
Adam's apple for it yeah and finally
Hodor oh ho hold the door we see a bit
more of his origin story his proper
origin story Willis we find out why he's
called Hodel why he says Hodor and it
turns out this confusing time paradox
where bran wargs into him in the past
which means he can Morgan to him in the
future in order to save himself good one
bran and the last instruction permit
from mirror is is hold the door and that
means past Willis / Hodor has a seizure
and he just repeats hold the door until
it becomes kind of bastardized into
Hodor ah which is like the lamest way of
where that word came from well duh at
least we now know it isn't horse or I
love you which was my theory but also
this came from george RR martin yeah it
wasn't the TV as they know this is canon
yeah like this is gonna happen in the
books too yeah rip big man alright be
gentle giant we're gonna save talking
about the big man and all the
implications of brands stupid failing to
obey orders in a little bit so let's
talk about what cuz other stuff avenues
episode actually some quite interesting
stuff i want to kick things off a little
finger cuz he's my boy he's back and
even though it seems like Sansa
completely rebuffed him he is clearly
like one or two steps ahead of everyone
else still so when he meets up a sansa
Sansa finds out from him that brynden
tally her great-uncle also known as the
blackfish a very famous like military
man is back at Riverrun so he was at the
red wedding managed to survive and
escape and now somehow he's managed to
get all of the Knights all the tally
nights back and he's managed to take
back Riverrun but um I'm just gonna go
on a limb here and say this is a trap
because Sansa has only heard it from one
man like the least trustworthy man in
all of Westeros and I just find it weird
to believe that that's what happened um
we only have little fingers word for it
and also why I find a bit weird was that
Sansa lied yeah and she didn't explain
why Brienne goes white why did you lie
and then it just sort of cuts away yeah
cuz probably everyone if she said a
little thing I told me Evan be like
little fingers old you yeah you don't
know we're not going we're not going
there anymore untrustworthy so Nick she
knows he's untrustworthy and that's why
she lied but one I wonder if his offer
to give the Knights of the Vale to her
were was a genuine offer because it sort
of seems like it might have been like
he's already secured that with Robin if
he wants to be warden of the north he's
going to have to help out the Starks
some point unless he just hopes that
like the stocks will just wipe
themselves out and he'll swoop in at the
end like the the the bastard bottle just
wiped both sides out and he'll just
swoop in at the end with the Knights of
the Vale but either way he's got Brienne
out of at the wall Brienne sent out on a
run with pod and for some reason
male malice Andrews is tagging along and
also tormund he's been sent to to
Riverrun to treat with the blackfish
hopefully this means that we'll get some
more tormund Giantsbane incredible
moments on the road down but also I know
we talked about this all the time and it
hasn't happened yet but in the books
this is the path the Brienne takes to
gum she ends up in Riverrun and then she
ends up the quiet I'll shins up a lady
stoneheart I don't know it's a big book
thing I'm like yeah Lady Stoneheart
really been not really a part and a show
and I mean everyone's kind of hoping
that the Hound will come back so this is
very interesting I don't know it's
interesting to see how that they're
doing it now it would have happened in
like book for something right so she'd
been go Susan but I'm kind of holding
out for that happening fingers crossed
it's all down to my boy pearl Jorah yeah
we do love to make fun of the guy but
it's at this point it's kind of like
being dead horse or a dead bear they're
innocent his house origins so last
season we saw him get the gray scale and
obviously we don't know much about his
disease so it could go on forever it
could it could have been a week for him
hmm but as we know for most case it's a
death sentence we've only ever seen one
person survive grayscale yeah and that
was a child yeah it was a child I mean
Judds children are more the resilient
may bounce back I logistic like chicken
pox where you can survive in childhood
but maybe not also also Stannis got like
maesters from all over the world like
all the world's best healers yeah but
the point remains that she did survive
so cure does exist I mean kind of I
don't know if it was any specific thing
maybe was like a combination of all the
stuff that they did yeah like an
accidental we just stumbled across a
cure yeah and then no one wrote it down
well after the escapades in vase
Dothraki mmm we are knowing his days are
numbered he explains that by the way
this this is a thing I need to worry
about so I'm gonna take off he loves
that little sleeve reveals though he
needs to change his shirt by the way
he's been wearing that for about three
weeks even sionary her clothes burned
off and you a new dress you still got
the womb
his other arm when he was on that
gladdie a fight hmm anyway he fully
declares his love and she basically says
what's pretty much just saying thanks no
no she did like the double blue tick
scene oh yeah she's read the messages I
just I'm not replying to that but what
do you think is gonna happen now like
she's obviously like you said he's
ordered to go find a cure do you think
he's gonna find that cure and come back
or what do you think the future fedora
if he if he wants to be proper like I
love you'll do anything for you then I
guess yeah if she wants him to find a
cure he'll do it for her not for him
button but that's kind of weird where's
Wade you even start you go to like
volantis they know things magic folk and
yeah or old town yeah well the maesters
are there there are a lot of red priests
hanging out oh no hang on what if like
Sam goes to old town and jor ends up in
old town and like Sam cures jour because
Jorah Mormont there the old Lord
Commander was a Mormon and he'd be like
oh my god we've got all these ties I'm
gonna cure you Oh God yeah you don't
sound impressed oh hey George hey I
joram Owen maybe I see so much of myself
in him I honestly think that the only
way his storyline is gonna end is with
him yeah I'm kind of imagining I don't
know actually how gray scale properly
ends but like his face turning to stone
and just before it gets to his mouth he
goes no la vio don't I turn into stone
men yeah they turned him is like
horrible like berserkers unless he he's
so taken with his love for the Khaleesi
that when he turns into a stone man he
retains his brain and his manner and he
just is her watchful stone protector so
so like the plot of what is it dead
bodies the one with the zombie that
falls in love oh that movie that I've
seen it we all think this is just gonna
happen to Dora yeah other stuff right
and so we don't think he's gonna get
cured I think it's gonna get killed I
hope he gets good I becomes back and
he's like like in the midst of a battle
you see some some valiant Knight Turner
and then the end after doing bad a
stuffy tears of his heroin is like Jorah
back in my house my arms better what if
the cure is love oh that's
I should save it for Disney are you
basically saying that George the beast
from the abyss yes he just needs true
love ahora me Danny get himself a proper
girlfriend i know i'm not saying Danny
I'm saying a new woman turns out pop
what if it's the red priestess confirmed
so we finally saw the kings / queens /
Greyjoy moot it wasn't actually that
exciting I swear in the books it was
this sort of like kind of raucous
meeting that went on for it went on from
many chapters and you know there were a
lot of political discussions and okay
that was boring but at least it was this
huge event where is here it was like ash
we meet in the garden ten minutes all
right there's a lot of dudes there that
look like they all needed a bath yeah
well like a seafaring [ __ ] yeah one much
exactly yeah and in the end it all it
was was Yara goes I should be queen seon
goes year she's real good and then
you're in goes no he has no penis vote
me yeah I campaign slogan convincing
campaign I've ever seen he's like the
weird uncle owned he comes around at
Christmas I think I kills your current
Cain kills you I need éclairs himself
king of your house that happen a lot I'm
from the north man yeah as it turns out
that the pike island is a pretty easily
won over he does all these promises you
know I'm gonna marry generis she's gonna
be impressed with this and they were
like way Queens can't do that lads so I
guess he wins just because they say his
name a lot that's kind of an informal
process but sure and then they drown him
but then he's not drowned and that's all
great but its first act is to kill his
niece and nephew but all they nicked his
fleet he can't do that I love that issue
the first thing he said was where's my
niece and nephew let's go murder let's
go kill him and but why are we back in
urine or Yara how I dro hi mostly Iran
seems a bit crazy unhinged yeah well he
is unhinged I mean like we know about
his shape silence and yeah people with
their tongues cut out last time there
was an unhinged ruler he burned a bunch
of people so that might be Brownsville
so I could be friends no I don't know I
kind of like your honors a just wild
card I don't think he was as wild as the
books made him he was this mad pirate
dude with all these rumors and
horrible things he done to people
whereas here he's just a guy with a bit
of a strange accent I guess you couldn't
really like if you introduced book yarn
and he like they gave him a lot of time
to sort of make him that crazy Rosen is
like he was in like one episode and then
he's yeah he's it he caught you can't
just go full crazy I was hoping to see a
bit more of like the sauce in him I
guess yeah like a bit more of foreign
customs like he comes back and he looks
the same as everyone else I was
expecting to be a no spicy lose be hasty
my teeth do we think Theon's ever gonna
stand up for himself some point I reckon
he will and he'll surprise us yeah maybe
maybe that's his like final thing that
he does right like his like challenge
someone to a duel to saves wasn't want
someone maybe it'll be like save his
sister oh and speaking of his sister do
we think this episode is is emblematic
of the series finally coming round to
the fact that like the women in the show
was so much better than some of the guys
like Sansa is like get off your ass John
I'm gonna get take the north back
brooding John gah Yara go I should be
Queen and the ongoing yeah she's a river
she's a warrior we got Denarius find me
being Denarius again after so bloody
long dealing tenaris mean setting
herself on fire cuz she's doing twice
yeah well yeah but yeah there was a bit
in between when she was Khaleesi and and
the bit now where she sort of didn't
really do anything she sat down a lot
missile looking at wieners yeah but you
mean raised a good point le about who
burned dinero says plea yes was it your
on did he do on purpose right yeah cuz
if he then goes over with his fleet and
Daenerys is like I need a fleet and he's
like a girl I got you fleet time now for
a segment I mean in my notes I've just
written god dammit bran because I mean
we said this a couple weeks ago right
that everything in Westeros is pretty
much brands fault and now confirmed
everything is brands fault so I mean in
this episode alone he caused the death
of summer leaf yep all of the children
in the forest tired children of the
forest so they're pretty much extinct
now I mean though it was set up they
were like oh
yeah they created the White Walkers so
they did the bad thing and now they're
all dead but it was brands for the
three-eyed Raven that was Brownsville
time was gonna do that Flores though yes
tria and hold or so thanks bran but
what's also kind of definitely been
confirmed now is that not only can bran
seemingly travel through time with his
his dreams he can influence people he
can be heard and he can also be touched
so where else in the series could he
have been I think we were saying so mad
king eres when but just before he
threatened to burn King's Landing he
said the same thing you've been saying
for hours burned them all Jaheim that
was a brand joint oh like ninety percent
a brand joint I think we've seen in the
trailer something that might be a
flashback and to Jamie doing is
Kingslayer thing I think there's
definitely be a flashback around then
and brands already there he might as
well mess everything up mm-hm there's an
interesting theory about because I mean
a lot of the Starks are called Brandon
mm-hmm it was brand builder there was
his uncle who's also called Brian and
it's sort of interesting that there was
a story read to them by old nan where
she keeps confusing the brands and so
now people are like wait what if all the
brands are the same which is kind of
blowing my mind what do we think is idea
um I think that might be a bit far I
think he could be one of the brands
maybe leave the young brown around the
Builder I think he could easily be but
maybe not all the brands and there's a
lot of you know everyone has the same
name in Game of Thrones yeah so it might
be a coincidence I'm fine with that well
at one point Ned does say to area after
area says like he can't be a night
anymore no but someday it could be Lord
of a holdfast or sit on the King's
Council one of my race cousins I'm
Brandon the Builder so that could just
be some insane foreshadowing or maybe
it's just a throwaway comment I mean to
be honest with the whole Hodor
elation like shadow for shadow age so
anything is possible and speaking of
Brian the Builder I think it's trying to
talk about the wall because I'm getting
this really weird feeling that it's
gonna come tumbling down soon it was
built it's it's you know bit load of ice
but also magic and it means that the
White Walkers can't come past it pretty
much like where the three-eyed Raven was
they couldn't come past the magic but
now the brands been touched that magic
see me doesn't work in areas that he's
in so basically if he goes past the wall
now does that mean that the White
Walkers can follow him is that why the
night's king kind of let him go at the
end I think that could be the big
cliffhanger of this series yes something
to do with the wall sammy's do with the
White Walkers coming past a certain
point yeah and it's a song of ice and
fire they're definitely the ice you're
gonna happen also the last thing that
John says toodle-oo said when he leaves
the wall is don't look it down while I'm
gone I'll do my best so John saw uh I
don't solutions fault so it's fall birds
might be like II didn't like the 30
dudes that left might be anyone yeah end
on a nice round number thousandth Lord
Commander might as well yeah um but also
it's interesting where brands gonna go
from here because in the books they were
supposed to meet cold hands who is kind
of this half I guess where you know he's
kind of like a like a white like a white
Walker but he's sort of regain he's kept
his human side strongly speculated that
he is benjin Benjen stark Ned's brother
who was a member of the Nights Watch I
don't know could that be humira meet up
with because she can't carry him
conquering brand myself I mean people
really like the benjin equals dario
equals your own theory benjin is all of
us engine equals all the men with
slightly long hair why don't for now I
think I mean I think this is pretty much
we're finally getting more of a like a
road map of where the series is heading
now so if the wall does come
down the ice definitely comes down with
it they'll come further and further
south if Denarius does come across from
sr so even if it's on her own chips or
if it's on yarrow ships or if it's on
your own ships also you're on is like I
won a thousand ships like in 10 minutes
build me a thousand ships and i will
give you this world
don't know how he thinks I'm building
works he's got the instant build sheets
turned on pretty much so that's the fire
element I'm just really interested to
see like that's the song of ice and fire
where does John fit on into all of it
where are the Starks gonna fit into the
rest of it yeah man just want to see
some dragons melt some ice dudes and set
some zombies on fire an interesting
thing I noticed in this episode is that
we now have mirror and bran going down
to the wall possibly even to Winterfell
because of course Brown wants to go back
to Winterfell so we've got a read in a
stark quite else have we seen that I
swear to God if we don't discover what's
in the Tower of joy yeah I'm gonna riot
time now definitely you should this is a
part where I really enjoy we talk about
all the fun deaths per ounce at this
time basis I mean oh yeah Oh God so I
mean like when one summer copped it I
think we all went Oh two or possibly
three dials left we known I Mary's out
there you know ghost is fine maybe
shaggy dog but it's looking less likely
now just don't like seeing animals get
hurt really um you can CGI once see mr.
Jai ones then there's leaf admittedly
that was their own farts could have
thrown that weird magic pooper grenade
um but what was interesting about I mean
it's kind of obvious who's gonna be on
death of the week but there was this
really damn good bit of foreshadowing
from jacket nagar does death only come
for the wicked when we leave the decent
behind
Oh
you are the winning my way
okay another spoiler warning this time
so if you want to go into season six
episode 6 blood of my blood completely
fresh and you didn't watch the next time
on game of thrones teaser trailer then
look away now because we're gonna be
having a look at making some predictions
as to what's going to be in next week's
episode so I mean first up got mirror
and bran wise but mais mirror saying I'm
so sorry um see I didn't even think it
sounded like her voice oh no I thought
it might be a flashback voice oh god
what if it's liana in the Tower of joy
that's what I'm so sorry Ned yeah
promise me Ned hmm I could be
interesting but also it seems like in
one of these flashes that one of these I
don't know you think they're a white
Walker who think that they are white
could that be a mysterious other this
could be cold hands they don't swap that
round yeah looks like a wraith yeah cuz
I mean she can't Mira cannot carry Brown
by yourself that way they do not have
much of a head start yeah which makes me
wonder if they're switching the story
lines around a little bit yeah we also
see Sam taking Gilly home um and you get
to see some well tallies dad who doesn't
look very nice that look that his dad
gives him when he sees his new paramour
yeah I am genuinely sure that my mother
has given me that look I brought home a
girlfriend and you've time to be ex is
my bastard son and she's like day for be
done did you find it off the wall get
out mouse oh but yeah so this interest
to see if he'll accept Gilly it's that
you hear that Gilley says you didn't you
didn't tell him I'm a wildling did you
too mmm no and then we get to see that's
gonna be a King's Landing episode we
didn't get anything from King's Landing
this episode also no dawn for four or
five four episodes are yeah it's happy
yeah ticking along by itself sir stop
having and Dawn so this could be
Marjorie's walk that's gonna get
interrupted by the Tyrell forces so we
see them around the scepter bail or
Cersei let let me show them what we do
to our enemies so I the enemies here
could be the faith
everyone could be there the laterals
goes everywhere unofficial motto we hate
everyone you also get a brief flash of
Tommen with the high Sparrow what's he
doing this time just ripping his
backbone out uh and then we did last
episode just keep doing it then we got
Dario and Daenerys note that jour is not
this he's clearly wandered off somewhere
to find a cure he's been ordered to find
his cure um generis is like I'll take
what's mine oh he's like he's giving him
more goddamn titles he's like an
ordinary reconquer mm-hmm her business
cards about that long at this point um
so I mean that must me you know she goes
back to marine mmm tries to but I mean
the thing is Taryn and virus have worked
up a damn piece yeah well wandering in
here with a damn army I'm not sure their
piece is as good as they think is they
say it's fragile anyway but I mean they
said oh we've managed to avoid Civil War
but I think they're gonna cause a civil
war mmm dragons are gonna have to come
out soon I'm getting I'm getting antsy
I'm waiting for dragons so that was
season 6 episode 5 the door and Hodor no
it's too soon okay I'm still too full of
emotion Kate what did you think it's
episode easily the best one so far I
think I'd give it a nine point five damn
Dave I really enjoyed it there were a
bit too many fields with this at first
they got a monday nothing I got through
it began I really enjoyed the episode I
thought I mean like the only weak point
in episode of me and this is quite
strange is the aria bit just because I
thought that play went on a little bit
too long we're really hammering home the
point that it was a test I mean I don't
I don't think you guys have seen this
but there's a bit in Avatar where they
do an entire play over an entire episode
that kind of covers everything that's
happened up until that point and it's
amazing it's the best episode I think
they were trying to go for that maybe I
thought you were talking about avatar no
no I mean I see you Jake Sully and as I
known there's no play it is that way
doesn't it may be I don't is a play but
we'll be back again next week with our
recap of season 6 episode 6 blood of my
blood obviously hinting towards a
generis episode with the Dothraki if you
liked this episode make sure to thumbs
up find us on iTunes as well i canna
stew
audio version just search for gamespot
of Thrones and we will see you next
Monday
you